[Applause]
fantastic sir please join us no no no i
don't think that the whole show was just
us gesturing to each other
if if i sit down before you he hits me
later yeah all right let's have a seat
ryan so nice of you to be here
[Applause]
that was nice to me to pretend some of
those screams were for me uh
ryan thanks so much for being here
always a pleasure having you on the show
thank you for having me back you know i
fiasco i really weighed this decision
carefully
is ryan is it time for him to come back
yes i'll allow it this one time yes
let's wait till that gosling turns into
a goose
what the hell i don't know
waiting for years to say that
look he never gets to say that uh you
know singing today
all the ways that you and i are exactly
the same uh
i don't know why people would giggle
with that uh
but i did find out something we have in
common you and i uh both i didn't
realize you i took dance class when i
was a young kid and so did you is that
right i knew you were a kid dancer
there's something about me that says i
can't tell a kid dancer i can i can spot
one from a mile away
that's the creepiest thing anyone's ever
seen
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know you just feel when we're in the
same room together
i sensed it too the minute you walked
out i was like a fellow child dancer
you used to tap dance right i tell when
i was a kid i was interested in tap
dancing it was absurd but i was like i
gotta be in show business someday i
better know how to tap dance
my voice never changed uh
anyway i'm surprised because that string
dance that you've invented is one of the
greatest dances of all time
seriously
[Applause]
that's all right i like the string dance
you like the string dance you show me
someone who doesn't like the string
dance i'll show you a liar
no there's string there's a lot of water
sounds what's going on when i'm looking
at it it's like
when i do the string dance you go in
it's just like it's like one of those
posters remember where you had to kind
of cross your eyes to see what was
really there yeah yeah
it reminds me of that it's sort of like
it makes me feel like uh like i'm a
better person after i've seen it
[Applause]
have you ever attempted this string
dance you seem like such a fan of a
string dance have you ever tried it in
the comfort the privacy of your own home
that's not fair what that's not a fair
thing to ask
i'm entitled i'm can ask anything i want
at conan
you know for i am coming you know i ca
you know i can't do the string dance
nobody can
i have a friend who died trying to do
this
he probably used real string
okay if you ever maybe just knowing it
around you ever just do it for your
girlfriend or something you ever just do
the string dance for her you know
by the way what's going on between you
and my girlfriend
what do you mean what's going on i told
her i was doing the show mm-hmm and she
said oh my god i love conan
i love conan
and i said i said what the what what was
that she said what i'm just saying i
love conan i love conan
i said look how how come you keep saying
it twice
and how come when the last the second
time you say it you kind of say it like
sombra and to yourself
and squeeze a wine glass till it
shatters i love him i love him
yeah well some guys got it
[Applause]